en los últimos años ha habido motines en
ecuador brasil venezuela y colombia a
qué se debe esto cómo están las cárceles
de la región
mira las cárceles son
sitios totalmente olvidados abandonados
donde reina la ley del más fuerte son
las mafias las pandillas los carteles
los que controlan la vida de la
población y la vida y adentro al
interior de las cárceles es un infierno
no hay servicios médicos están asignados
es decir la sobrepoblación es la regla
en algunos casos hay unos altísimos
porcentajes que llegan por ejemplo el 50
por ciento como en brasil de personas
que están procesadas sin condenas es
decir estás sujetas a una prisión
preventiva
y no aún no están condenadas eso
incrementa notablemente el número de
reclusos y el espacio es muy limitado y
las condiciones son realmente de vida
infrahumanas